حسنًا ، قالت عضوة الكونجرس الإسرائيلي ، إله وعمر ،
أمس إن على الولايات
المتحدة أن تعيد التفكير في سياستها الخاصة بالمساعدة
تجاه إسرائيل بعد أن اعتقدت هي وعضوة في
الكونجرس أنه تم رفض دخول
عضو الكونجرس طالب ، ولكن
سُمح له لاحقًا بتوجيه قرارها
بعدم إجراء أي تغيير في المساعدات الأمريكية إلى إسرائيل.
إسرائيل لا ويجب أن ترى
الأشياء الفظيعة التي قالها طالب
عن إسرائيل و AOC +3 وهذا ما
أسميه SC ، فقط خذ O + 3
ويجب أن ترى الأشياء
التي قالها الأربعة عن إسرائيل على مدار
الزوجين الماضيين  لسنوات
، أعني أن عمر كارثة للشعب اليهودي
لا أستطيع أن أتخيله إذا كان لديها أي
يهودي في منطقتها
يمكن أن يصوتوا لصالحه ولكن ما قاله عمر
ما قاله طالب لا يمكنني
حتى تصديق أننا  إجراء هذه
المحادثة
قبل خمس سنوات ، حتى إن مفهوم
الحديث عن هذا حتى قبل ثلاث سنوات
من قطع المساعدات عن إسرائيل بسبب
شخصين يكرهان إسرائيل ويكرهانان
الشعب اليهودي لا أصدق أننا حتى
إجراء هذه المحادثة حيث
ذهب الحزب الديمقراطي إلى
حيث ذهبوا حيث دافعوا عن هذين
الشخصين ضد دولة إسرائيل
وأعتقد أن أي شعب يهودي يصوت لصالح
ديمقراطي أعتقد أنه يظهر إما نقصًا تامًا
في المعرفة أو عدم ولاء كبير